congressman Bernie Sanders is a fearless
advocate for consumer rights and for
economic justice it's an honor to have
him as part of our presentation
congressman Bernie Sanders good Thank
You Dennis now we're going to shock you
let's say something very radical hard to
believe the Progressive Caucus actually
believes that the United States Congress
should represent ordinary Americans
rather than big oil companies it's a
shocking statement I know and we think
we think there is something wrong when
the big oil companies who have
contributed tens and tens of millions of
dollars to political parties and to the
campaign of the President of the United
States are able to get back their
campaign investments 10 20 50 times back
because of the huge profits they're
currently making under the deregulated
system that the President and others
have pushed at a time when communities
in the state of Vermont and throughout
this world are making successful strides
toward reducing the energy we consume
President Bush is proposing to slash the
federal energy conservation budget by
more than a third at a time when
countries throughout the world are
investing substantial sums of money in
alternative energy which is now cost
effective which is now working the
president is slashing the budget of
investment in alternative energies in my
own City of Burlington Vermont where I
used to be a mayor as a result of
intelligent energy conservation programs
Burlington homeowners have cut energy
consumption by twenty-five percent over
the last 10 years and other communities
around the country have done equally as
well if we are investing in energy
conservation if we are vesting an
alternative energy if we are prepared to
break up
the energy cartels and stand up to them
and protect the consumers we can
substantially lower the cost of energy
in this country and we can have energy
being produced in environmentally and
sustainably sound wave I applaud Dennis
and the Progressive Caucus for leading
the way and the American people are
listening they want us to have the guts
to stand up to the big money people and
energy and that's precisely what we're
going to do